today is an historic day for Croatia and
for the European Union nearly nine years
since you applied for membership after
six years of negotiations the accession
treaty of Croatia to the European Union
is ready for signature Croatia is said
to become the 28 member states of the
union
welcome to the European Union the
signing ceremony was the crown of the
very long process that started on the
3rd of October 205 it took a number of
years to accomplish so finally when the
signatures were put on our accession
treaty that was well symbolically and
practically the end of the very very
long process
after the accession treaty signed you
acquire a status of permanent observer
and you can participate in almost all
the working bodies and all the counsel
of the Mysterio meetings and European
Council meetings and of course the world
of the council becomes fully opened to
you it has been absolutely beneficial
and fantastic experience to be able to
sit in the meetings of the Foreign
Affairs Council and in the meetings of
the General Affairs Council but also my
colleagues are sitting in the way
caffeine and the agricultural ministers
council and of course the Prime Minister
is sitting is sitting in the meetings of
the European Council although we don't
have a vote until we are full members we
have everything else we have we have the
possibility to hear what people are
saying we have the possibility to be
here when the decisions are being made
we have the possibility to debate and
discuss and express our opinions the
same as everybody else
with every enlargement we need new staff
to come and work with the EU so in view
of the upcoming adhesion of Croatia to
the EU the European personnel selection
office has started since last summer
with the selection of Croatian staff in
different fields we are running
selection procedures for general
administrators for translators and
interpreters and for assistance in the
field of project management law and
communication so by the 1st of July we
will have selected about 360 Croatian
staff to come and work with the EU
institutions
Poliquin silicon say ash residue PFF
availa do a formation telenovela meteor
the jicama seen an avant that is your
delicacy
well Croatia entering the European Union
is is a big big thing in our country and
as being here it's really exciting to
take part in the whole process it's a
very good feeling that our language is
now part of the family of languages here
the council and that creation language
will now become the 24th language of the
European Union so it is a great honor
and it's very exciting to to feel part
of the whole project of European unity
when Croatia caught candidate status and
we start accession talks the number of
journalists guru so there are between
eight and ten I travelled from Zagreb to
Brussels one per month sometimes often
but when we become the member of the
European Union bristle we will be our
second capital institutions are adopting
to the fact that we as a Croatian term
we start here and we have questions that
are not only about enlargement anymore
but all all the different issues and
portfolios or hopes for the future of
course hi first on the first of July we
gonna enjoy for a couple of hours the
beauty and miracle of the membership and
then back to the hard work because the
work in European Union a brand's we
really do feel at home around the
council tables and it's a very very good
feeling